Russia has released an American citizen
in a mass prisoner swap in Ukraine The
Prisoner was a U.S Air Force veteran who
was living in the country of Ukraine and
detained by pro-russian forces several
months ago MTS tayab is in Ukraine with
the latest on this extraordinary release
a show of defiance as 64 Ukrainian
soldiers were released in a prisoner
swamp with Russia among them swedi
murakasi
hello my name is sweetie Marchesi and uh
I am well the American Air Force veteran
who's lived in the southern Ukrainian
city of her son since 2018. it was
occupied by Russian forces at the start
of the war and he was taken into custody
in early June before the city's
liberation last month
morikezi was reportedly Accused by
Moscow of taking part in pro-ukrainian
protests and was held in a cell with
Americans and fellow veterans Alex
drewke and Andy Wen
before their release in September
there's been a sharp increase in
prisoner exchanges between Russia and
Ukraine in recent months even as the
Kremlin continues to Target Ukrainian
towns and cities including the capital
Kiev where residents were showered with
fragments of iranian-made drones all 13
of the explosives Laden Shaheed 136s
were shot out of the sky by Ukrainian
air defenses
is the head of Ukraine's Security
Council Russia has been using
iranian-made drones to Target sites here
the Russians are unable to defeat us on
their own he says I would advise Iran to
take that into account because if they
also start supplying Russia with
missiles to attack us they would be
Crossing alive
Allah in Tehran appears willing to cross
as Russia continues to exhaust its
missile supplies but with the Biden
Administration poised to announce it
will provide Ukraine with Patriot air
defense systems well that could be the
Game Changer in this grinding War Nate
MTS type in Ukraine thank you